das thema ist geld das andere thema ist
unser sommerurlaub wir hören wirklich
schockierende nachricht aus mallorca das
schreiben experten und insider die ganze
saison schon ab vielleicht gibt es
irgendwie im september vielleicht noch
vielleicht nochmal ein konzert aber
partys mit sicherheitsabstand kann ich
mir ehrlicherweise schwer vorstellen und
einer der das weiß ist peter berg auf
erst der deutsche arzt am ballermann
herberg auf wie ist die lage auf
mallorca wie ist die stimmung
die stimmung ist stunden still ist ja
überhaupt keine
es gibt ausgangssperren viel strenger
als in deutschland hier sieht das ganze
viel viel strenger aus auch wenn medien
föderalismus haben ihr wird in madrid
gesagt was gesagt getan wird und das
wird auch überall getan
es gibt keine flüge es gibt keine reisen
es wird keiner hereingelassen
es ist keine kneipe auf es ist keine
gaststätte auf es steht alles still
doch patienten da kommt wieder mal einer
werden rezept braucht aber sonst sehr
langweilig in der praxis aber wie läuft
das sie sind ja dann ist so ein bisschen
darauf die partypeople sozusagen
angewiesen der eine trinkt ein bisschen
zu viel hat einen sonnenbrand
die kommen dann zu ihnen wie ist das im
moment machen sich da auch sorgen um
ihre zukunft
also was die praxis angelegt da lässt
sich im augenblick kein geld
mitverdienen da muss man ersparnisse da
reinstecken und das nachdem der winter
gerade vorbei ist ich persönlich bin ein
bisschen besser aufgestellt ich habe
noch eine firma die immobilien von
deutschen betreut und die brauchen im
augenblick betreuung und da kann man
noch etwas machen haben sie diese sorgen
denn auch schon abgeschrieben
ich habe diese saison vollkommen
abgeschrieben
und ich bin noch nicht mal sicher dass
wir im nächsten jahr im april schon eine
saison haben schauen sie es muss ein
stoff gefunden werden es muss ein
dort getestet werden man muss wissen wie
lange sind die leute immun und es muss
auch in allen ländern aus denen gereist
wird eine ziemliche sicherheit geben die
gefahr ist dass das virus ansteckend ist
bevor der patient symptome zeigt das
heißt am flughafen stehen und die
einreisenden mit der wärmekamera zu
untersuchen ist völliger quatsch die
können trotzdem infektiös sein und
menschenansammlungen wird es nicht geben
und abgesehen davon die playa wird im
nächsten jahr ganz ganz anders aussehen
als wir sie kennen da sind wir gespannt
wir hoffen dass die party in irgendeiner
form weitergeht danke schön herr
berghoff und natürlich machen sich viele
zuschauer sorgen ums geld also klar der
mallorca urlaub ist längst gebucht
was mache ich damit kriege ich das geld
wieder an kämpft jetzt müssen sie noch
mal in die bütt springen wie gehe ich da
jetzt am besten vor
muss ich mich informieren oder zock ich
oder warte ich ab
was ist da so ihr rat also im grunde
genommen geht es ja um drei typen
erstmal die leute die sowieso schon
storniert haben die ihr geld jetzt
hinterher laufen die sollen ein bisschen
druck machen und eben die gesellschaften
in verzug setzen
diejenigen die jetzt in kürzester zeit
reisen wollen die sollen jetzt überlegen
ob sie vielleicht noch überlegen dass
die reise vielleicht stattfindet dann
und sie auch die reise in anspruch
nehmen wollen dann sollten sie jetzt im
grunde genommen noch ein bisschen
abwarten gucken was so passiert denn
wenn die reise stattfindet dann ist es
ja ok und wenn wir jetzt reisen haben
die in fernerer zukunft sind dann sollte
man wirklich überlegen ob man jetzt
diese günstigere stornierungsmöglichkeit
in je länger ich werde desto teurer ist
ja die stornierung diese günstigere
stornierungsmöglichkeit wahrnehme etwas
abschläge hinnehmen
dann aber die reise erst einmal das geld
zurückbekomme
und dann vielleicht wenn es dann wieder
weitergeht dann kann ich nur neue reise
buchen weil ich persönlich glaube dass
es dann günstiger wird das erscheint mir
gerade der richtige weg zu sein aus
rechtsgründen erstmal abwarten was
passiert den markt genau beobachten und
wenn ich dann storniere vielleicht mit
nach steuern eine gebühr von 30
kann ich dann sicher sein dass ich auch
wirklich bargeld bekommen oder versucht
mich der anbieter dann gutscheine
abzuspeisen
im grunde genommen ist das so ein
bisschen die reflex wirkung
dieser diskussion um die gutscheinlösung
die gutscheinlösung ist ja wenn man so
will ein kredit für den unternehmer für
die veranstalter was ja für die
veranstalter natürlich gut ist und man
kann auch überlegen ob man damit
einverstanden ist denn wenn jetzt alle
dem geld hinterherlaufen dann besteht
die gefahr dass es dazu insolvenzen
kommen könnte also von daher kann das
auch was gutes sein und die diese
gutscheinlösung die immer wieder
angesprochen wird ist ja noch nicht
umgesetzt die müsste europäische
umgesetzt werden weil das deutsche
airline hat ist da gar nicht möglich und
die ersten signale die man zu diesem
thema so aus der kommission hört ist
dass man das skeptisch ist so das nicht
persönlich glaube diese gutscheinlösung
wird wahrscheinlich gar nicht kommen
und es ist natürlich immer besser für
den verbraucher den reisenden besser
bargeld zu haben also gutschein zu haben
das ist für den reisenden besser ganz
klar